[Music]
straight ahead all lawn crime daily
a huge victory for britney spears jamie
spears
is no longer a conservator
after 13 years under his reign spears's
father suspended from her
conservatorship and dog is on the hunt
the search now
is really on reality star dog the bounty
hunter says he's hot on the trail for
fugitive brian laundry as the fbi
returns to his parents home we'll
explain and later family ties put to the
test were you aware you had a 22 caliber
rifle
i was aware my father had given him one
at some point the defendant's brother
takes the stand in the mennonite murder
trial law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin it's official britney spears's
father has been suspended as a
conservator of her estate a major
victory for the pop star in her quest to
bring the 13-year conservatorship to an
end law and crimes anjanet levy is here
with what britney and jamie spears are
saying about the suspension
brian as you can imagine jamie spears is
not happy about this suspension despite
his calls to end the conservatorship but
for britney spears and her fans this
brings her one step closer to freedom
jamie spears
is no longer a conservator
it's the day britney spears and her fans
have been waiting for for years judge
brenda penny suspended jamie spears as
conservator of brittany's estate her
attorney matthew rosengart says the
suspension will allow him to examine
communications between jamie spears and
his advisors
the attorney-client communications
between mr spears on the one hand
and his lawyers on the other
i believe will reveal
corruption
in that regard i don't know what's going
to happen
after this comes out the suspension
comes after the release of two new
documentaries about the conservatorship
controlling britney spears by the new
york times claims spears's security team
eavesdropped on her and surveilled her
at her father's request his attorney
says they analyzed those claims and the
documentary is quote not evidence
jamie spears had filed documents to
terminate the conservatorship his
attorney issued a statement calling the
latest hearing a loss for brittany
vivian thorin said respectfully the
court was wrong to suspend mr spears put
a stranger in his place to manage
brittany's estate and extend the very
conservatorship that britney begged the
court to terminate despite the
suspension mr spears will continue to
look out for the best interests of his
daughter and work in good faith towards
a positive resolution of all matters
[Applause]
spears's fans gathered in mass outside
the courthouse to show their support
this is bigger than brittany this is
for all the thousands of people that are
incorrupt conservatorships we will keep
advocating until brittany is a
completely free woman which hopefully
will happen at her next hearing on
november 12th and on instagram spears
posted a video of her learning to fly a
plane saying on cloud nine new picks
coming soon
now back to those claims that the
security team was eavesdropping on
britney spears her attorney matthew
rosengart said he expects law
enforcement to look closely at those
allegations and other things involving
britney spears and jamie spears the next
hearing is november 12th brian
thanks antoinette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike
corobotonix and terry austin mike many
people suspected foul play in jaime's
handling of britney's finances do you
think that this order to turn over 13
years of records will resolve those
worries
i think that's a very smart move by the
court because by turning those over that
will close any sort of mysteries there
and we will find out whether or not in
fact there was any fraud or was this
conservatorship truly in her best
interest of britney spears which is
supposed to be and i think those 13
years of documents will show gonna be
interesting to see how that plays out
terry jamie is out in a hearing to
terminate the conservatorship is set for
november do you think this is the
beginning of the end for the
conservatorship
i do think it's the beginning of the end
no doubt about it i think when britney
hired her new attorney matthew rosengart
that was the beginning of the end he
took it upon himself to help her get an
accounting now her father has been
suspended as a conservator and i think
he's also looking at the rest of the
estate jody montgomery is really the
conservator of her person and brittany
has said in the past that she's happy
with jody montgomery but we just saw
that very recently montgomery declined
now to ask for money for security for a
security team apparently she'd been
getting threatening emails so she's
backing off a little bit i definitely
think we're going to see an end to the
conservatorship probably at the next
hearing yeah that hearing is just right
around the corner and jeanette there is
still a conservator of the estate for
now though who is it
yeah his name is john zabal he is a cpa
and he was actually selected by matthew
rosengart and britney spears and
approved to take over as a temporary
conservator by judge penny
jamie spears though is calling him
unqualified and believes he could be
putting her finances and her estate in
danger so we'll see how long this lasts
john zabel is not the person they
initially selected they had initially
selected another person but now they've
brought john zabel on board instead
we still got a lot more updates as this
saga for britney spears continues and of
course we'll give you those updates as
they continue in the free britney saga
thank you everyone more updates now on
the federal trial against elizabeth
holmes former theranos lab associates
stating under oath they stopped using
the company's device after just one
month they say it's because the tests
weren't providing streamlined results
this week dr victoria song took the
stand detailing her work done with
theranos song worked for biotech startup
celgene a company that collaborated with
theranos from 2009 to 2012. sung
testifies the companies worked together
for just one month before celgene ended
its deal with theranos due to varying
test results and validation issues
founded back in 2003 holmes claimed the
now defunct theranos would revolutionize
blood testing later investigations found
many issues with his programs the former
billionaire faces 12 fraud charges in
connection to her time with the company
turning now to arkansas where child
pornography charges will stand against
reality tv star josh duggar duggar rose
to fame as the eldest son on the tlc
show 19 kids and counting in april
duggar was charged with two counts of
downloading and possessing child
pornography duggar pled not guilty he
faces up to 20 years in prison and fines
up to 250 thousand dollars on each count
if he's convicted on monday a federal
judge denied motions from the defense
seeking to dismiss the charges stating
that investigators took duggard's phone
and questioned him without a lawyer
present the prosecution argued that the
defendant was not in custody and he
voluntarily chose to speak with
investigators his trial is set to begin
on november 30th
still ahead on law and crime daily
friends and roommates take the stand
recounting the last moments they saw
sasha krauss alive but first dog the
bounty hunter is on the hunt for wanted
fugitive brian laundry all that and more
after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
federal canines and bounty hunters alike
dogs are sniffing out the trail of brian
laundry the fbi collecting laundry's
personal items for k-9 officers as dog
the bounty hunter narrows in on the
campground laundry visited before his
disappearance
this would be and could be a perfect
spot for him to hide
not too many people out here but there's
a lot of environmental things that we're
gonna
fight
the bounty hunters star is focusing his
search on the fort dussetto campground
area where laundry and his family went
camping earlier this month the fbi has
also obtained surveillance video from
the area to analyze meanwhile agents
arrive at the laundry family home on
thursday to collect personal items for
canines to sniff this as the laundry
family attorney confirms brian bought a
brand new cell phone after returning
home from a cross-country road trip
without gabby potito the attorney also
says brian left that phone at home
before he disappeared laundry has been
at large for more than two weeks as the
fbi manhunt in the florida reserve
continues laundry was last seen on
september 14th when he left his family
home without that cell phone or a wallet
as a laundry family attorney stephen
bertolino continues to make comments at
the about the case former america's most
wanted host john walsh put him on blast
there's a special place in hell for
stephen bertolino he's doing the johnny
cochran o.j simpson i'm going to get
this kid off and get my 15 seconds of
fame he's been colluding with the family
now this is all my own opinion so when
it comes time to get them for doing this
and given all these red herrings and
sending these cops into the swamp to
waste hundreds of thousands of dollars
he's going to say i didn't know what
would happen it's lawyer client
privilege
all right let's bring back criminal
defense attorney mike corobonix via
burner phone and co-host terry austin to
discuss the latest in the search for
brian laundry mike you and i are defense
attorneys who firmly believe in
innocence until proven guilty but
laundry's on the lam there's a rumor
about a burner phone him leaving the
wall and the phone before he disappears
how hard would it be to keep that
presumption when he's caught
well he's always going to have the
presumption because that's what our
constitution guides us with
until a jury finds differently
the problem is though is this is
not looking very well for the defense in
this matter because it does look like
there's a lot of information that is
being held about where he is
there is attorney-client privilege
up until acts committed
but after those acts are committed any
furtherance which is pointed out if he
is
escaping
and these things are throwing
officials off the hunt for lack of a
better term it is going to be
problematic for the defense and i think
they need to be very careful uh the
other thing is though brian i i'm really
not so sure if in fact he may not have
harmed himself because this is a very
complicated case and i'm sure we're
going to see some mental health issues
during in this case as well absolutely
no terry john walsh didn't mince his
words do you feel that the that the
laundry family and their attorney are
helping themselves or brian at all with
their comments
i think they are not helping themselves
christopher and roberta laundry have
actually been silent and they've been
talking only through their attorney and
the attorney is basically saying that
they have no idea where their son is and
i don't think that's helping
particularly since he returned from the
trip without gabby who was living with
them it doesn't make sense it's hurting
them yeah we'll see how this all plays
out as the man hunt for brian laundry
continues thank you both for your input
on to the latest twists in the murdah
murder mystery reports now say alec
murdoch's wife went sorry alec murdoch's
wife met with a divorce attorney ahead
of her murder
back in june maggie and paul murdo were
found murdered on their family property
six weeks earlier it's alleged that
murdoch's wife maggie met with a lawyer
to discuss ending her marriage to alec
in a statement to law and crime a
spokesman for alec murda says that claim
is inconsistent with what they have seen
over reviewing years worth of text
messages between the couple that show a
happy and loving relationship this comes
weeks after murder turned himself in to
police admitting he hired a hitman to
kill him so his surviving son would
receive an insurance payout murdo
survived the scheme and is facing
criminal prosecution
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest testimony from the mennonite
murder trial what the defendant's
brother says about their history with
the mennonite faith
[Music]
welcome back testimony is heating up in
arizona as mennonite witnesses take the
stand in the trial against a united
states airmen
twenty-two-year-old mark gooch is
accused of kidnapping and murdering
twenty-seven-year-old sasha krauss a
member of a new mexico mennonite
community gooch is charged with first
degree murder kidnapping and theft he
pled not guilty to all charges krauss
was last seen shopping for sunday school
supplies in january 2020. about a month
later her body was found near flagstaff
arizona at the time gooch was stationed
at an air force base in phoenix an
autopsy revealed krause died a blunt
force trauma and a gunshot wound to the
head a crime lab reported that the
bullet taken from kraus's skull was
fired from a gun that gooch had in his
possession cell phone records put gooch
in the area at the suspected time of the
crime this week members of the mennonite
community were called to the stand to
recount the moment they realized sasha
krauss was missing
later that evening did you get a phone
call about sasha
yes later that evening it was about 3 30
in the morning
lucinda hurst called
me
and woke me up and said do you know
where sasha is
um
when you got that phone call did you
take any action at that time
yes
samuel was beside me and he said what's
wrong
and i said lucinda says sasha missing
okay
did you leave the house to go help at
that point
i did not who about samuel yes he did he
got up he said well i can hardly believe
she's missing there seems to there has
to be an answer
so he got up
and got dressed and left right away
other friends of kraus described her
character saying she was hard-working
and sweet
was there
any difficulty in your relationship
there was some toward the last yes okay
um and i difficulty is my word but how
would you describe it what was going on
difficulty is a good way to put it
stress
okay and what was that related to
oh it was all my fault
okay in what way so
so we were co-workers
and
i wasn't keeping up my end of the of the
load
um
and sasha instead of
instead of coming to me and telling me i
wish you would
i wish you would carry your load better
i wish you would change what you're
doing she just sweetly
just started sort of taking over what i
was not getting done
on wednesday the defendant's brother
took the stand to testify samuel cooch
was given three months probation for a
separate but related case where he pled
guilty to the solicitation of to commit
hindering prosecution for getting rid of
the rifle that his brother allegedly
used in the shooting he also helped his
brother by covering his tracks digitally
after
his arrest did mark ask you to remotely
wipe his phone
yes i believe so
and not just his phone but the sd cards
as well
based on the transcripts that is correct
you remember when that conversation
occurred
i believe it was
shortly or within a few days of his
arrest
when we come back damning text messages
made against the mennonite people the
mennonite murder trial continues after
this
[Music]
welcome back we continue with testimony
in arizona where the brother of
defendant mark grouch takes the stand
the prosecution says gooch and his
brothers have expressed animosity
towards the mennonite community on
cross-examination sam gooch denied any
sign of hatred towards mennonites but
that was challenged on redirect
any
expression of animosity against the
mennonite church
and i think you said he never expressed
animosity right not animosity
occasionally have conversations
like mennonites would occasionally
reference but it was not a large part of
our conversations all right but if it
wasn't animosity what was the feeling
around the mennonites
i'm not quite sure what i can say what
mark's feelings would have been i know
as midnights
have been discussed in our conversations
right i guess what i'm getting at is
if it wasn't something negative then why
would you tell the police he had a
grudge against the mennonite community
the prosecution says this animosity was
showcased through text messages between
the three brothers the texts show one of
the brothers a police officer pulled
over a mennonite man to give him a
ticket texts detailing this incident
were read to jurors on wednesday
so your brother jake the police officer
indicates
he just gave him mennonite a ticket that
was a
this is a group text right to you and
mark gooch correct
and what was mark gucci's response
yes
yes and how many exclamation marks
four
all right and then what's his next text
on mark gooch i hope you treated him
what was your response
haha hell yeah tell them the va state
police doesn't like cultists all right
and then j goose talks about
coughing
can you read that
i coughed on him so he would spread
corona to the wedding they were going to
lol
all right mike maybe it's just me and
i'm drawing parallels between the
mcmichaels and aubrey and gooch and and
in this case here and we've been
discussing hate crime charges do these
text messages make it clear or confusing
that there are no such hate crime
charges in this case
not only they make it clear brian
in my opinion if i'm a juror and
watching how his brother denied on cross
any ill feelings or tried to minimize it
when he was confronted on redirect which
i thought was brilliant by the
prosecutor
it showed that that was clearly
one of the motivating factors here and
it really has me puzzled as to why
they didn't enhance the penalties and
charge him with a hate crime in this
matter i don't know i don't have the
file but that brief excerpt really
strengthens the case yeah i know they're
hard to prosecute but all the facts seem
to be there terry do these text messages
drive home the motive that the
prosecution is arguing krause was
murdered or did the defense negate that
in any way
oh i don't think the defense negated it
in any way shape or form and i agree
with mike this prosecutor is excellent
he has a cool calm manner and he is
questioning samuel about these text
messages and they do indicate that there
is quote unquote animosity against the
mennonite church and it also indicates
the fact that he was quote unquote
surveilling the church so i think yes
for the prosecution they've done a great
job so far all right thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you